what do you think marcus aurelius would
say about the current state of the
internet and social media and tribalism
and stuff like that he'd say maybe on
social media people are less able to
interrupt you you're not seeing the
facial expression and stuff you can also
just ignore them there are many people
that post office on social media and
never read any of the responses in
psychotherapy you know that to me sets
alarm bells ringing because people kind
of need the socializing effect of
getting feedback we need critics we need
disagreement in order to knock the rough
edges off our thinking some people are
so can a narcissist they just want to
put stuff out and not get any feedback
on it which is the opposite in the sense
of the peer review method like science
is all about stuff out there and then
you let everyone tear it to shreds and
that's kind of like how we learn stuff